LEAVE WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
WITH THE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATORS GALGIANI HERE -- JOHNNY
HERE WILL PRESENT.
PRESENT AVEIRO.
THEY'RE ALL HERE GALLEY GLAZER
[inaudible]
HE WE HAVE FIVE BILLS BEFORE IS
HERE TODAY AND WE HAVE AN AUTHOR
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
RIGHT AWAY I WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COME FORWARD IN PLEASE PRESENT A
BEFORE.
SEVENTEEN DEALING WITH
AGRICULTURE AND RURAL PROPER.
PROSPERITY.
MADAM CHAIR THAT ITEM I
UNDERSTAND IS ON CONSENT.
YOU HAVE A SECOND ITEM AB FOR
FIFTY DEALING WITH EASE AND
APIARY THE CAPTION ATTY
[inaudible]
CORRECT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS TODAY I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB FOR FIFTY WHICH IS A
FOLLOW UP TO LAST YEAR'S AB.
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT WHICH
PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE ON
CONSENT.
LAST YEAR AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
EIGHT CHANGE NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS. FOR A BEER IS
MOVING FROM ONE COUNTY TO
ANOTHER CHANGE THEM FOR FIVE
DAYS DOWN TO SEVENTY TWO HOURS.
WHAT WE FAILED TO DO LAST YEAR
WAS MAKE THAT SAME CHANGE WITHIN
COUNTY?
THAT OUR MISSION IS BEING
CORRECTED THIS YEAR.
WE ARE CLARIFYING THAT IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE SAME NOTIFICATION.
RELOCATION WITHIN THE SAME
COUNTY.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
MATT SEVERAL SERVER L<c.cyan>G BUT</c>
THE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS AND SEALERS
ASSOCIATION A SPONSOR OF AB.
FOR GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS MASS I REALLY ONLY HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER SINCE YOUR
DISSOCIATION.
BACK THIS YEAR'S TO CLEAN UP A
SMALL OVERSIGHT FROM A BILL WE
SPONSORED LAST YEAR TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
I COMMISSIONERS WHO ARE
ADMINISTERING THE APPLICATION OF
PESTICIDES NO.
WHERE WITHIN THE COUNTY OF
COMMERCIAL BE ACTIVITIES GOING
ON SO THOSE BEES ARE HARMED BY
DRIFTER ANY DIRECT APPLICATION
OF PASSES?
IT'S IT'S ALREADY CURRENT LAW
THAT THAT APPLICATORS AND ARE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE AREA
INDUSTRIES ARE ARE NOTIFYING THE
AYE COMMISSIONER THIS IS HIS
BOSS DURING THAT.
THAT CURRENT REQUIREMENT MAKING
SURE THAT WE KNOW WHERE THEY ARE
WE KEEP THEM SAFE AND WHO'D
ORGANIZED THE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
NOT IN SUPPORT.
JONATHAN CLAIM TO HAVE THE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO ALSO IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PEST CONTROL ADVISERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
CNN.
IS THE AUTHOR HAVE.
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'D LIKE US TO
ACCEPT YES THERE ARE SOME
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
SIDE WE'VE PRESENTED TO YOU AND
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ACCEPT OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS BY
MEMBERS AS SENATOR CANBERRA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
APPRECIATE -- THIS THIS BILL
THIS IS.
IMPORTANT GIVEN IS THE SITUATION
WITH THEM.
IT KIND OF BEES AND BE
POPULATIONS -- AT ONE POINT
THERE WAS DISCUSSION AND SOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AUTUMN BUT WE
MAY HAVE HAD THIS DISCUSSION
ABOUT -- AN APP. FOR BEING ABLE
TO DO GPS LOCATION AND AND AND
YOU MAY NOT HAVE INFORMATION
TERMS OF WEATHER THAT -- IN THE
TECHNOLOGY IS ADVANCED TO THAT.
EXTENT WHERE YOU CAN DO THINGS
ONLINE BECAUSE MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE ARE DOING THINGS WITH THE
PHONE AND IF YOU COULD.
YOU COULD DROP -- EIGHT A. M..
THE HIVES ARE THE BOXES AND IN.
IDENTIFY WHERE THEY'RE LOCATED
IN SEND THAT IT TRANSMIT THAT
INFORMATION TO THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS OFFICE OR WHOEVER
ELSE NEEDS TO KNOW WHERE THEY'RE
AT THAT WOULD BE A TERRIFIC.
TERRIFIC ADVANTAGE.
BUT I AM NOT SURE WHETHER THAT.
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS AVAILABLE YET.
IT SOUNDS AS IF THERE'S A
POTENTIAL PILOT IN OUR NEAR
FUTURE FOR US TO DISCUSS AND
WORK ON AND SEE IF.
IT HELPS CERTAIN COUNTIES TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL ISSUE BUT
PARTICULARLY IF THE APP ALSO
GIVES YOU NOTIFICATION THAT THE
HIVES ARE BEING MOVED BECAUSE
THAT'S THE OTHER THING IS THAT
THE THEFT OF THESE.
OF THESE HIVES IS IN IN -- IT'S
REALLY EXPENSIVE YOU COULD LOSE
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE
DAY IF SOMEONE COMES AND PICKS
UP YOUR LOW TELL [inaudible]
JUST [inaudible]
CHECKING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I I WILL
MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE BILL ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS QUESTIONS OKAY
WITHOUT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE THEM ALL.
AB FOR FIFTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED RE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS CAL
JOHNNY.
JOHNNY HI WILL.
WILK I HAVE A ZERO ZERO I VALLEY
GLAZER.
OKAY THAT BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES
BUT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND PUT ON
CALL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES WE CAN.
WE HAVE TWO BILLS PROPOSE FOR
CONSENT AB FOR SEVENTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA BETWEEN
MENTIONED EARLIER AND AB FIVE
NINETY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
WELL THE SECRETARY THESE CALL
THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SENATORS
GALGIANI AYE JOHNNY I WILL.
WELL I HAVE A HERO. ZERO AYE
DALY GLAZER.
HE WILL GO AHEAD AND PUT THOSE
ITEMS ON CALL.
AND WE HAVE.
ANOTHER MEMBER HERE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME FORWARD
AND PRESENT AB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT
DEALING WITH CANNABIS
CULTIVATION.
TOUR YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR.
AB.
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT AS A COUPLE OF
TECHNICAL CLEANUP SIGN CANOPY
SPACE AS WELL AS SOME
TERMINOLOGY CLEAN UP I ISSUES ON
APPELLATIONS OF ORIGIN.
RESPOND FASTER AGO.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YOU
HAPPEN TO HAVE MR LOUIS BROWN
RIGHT HERE.
AND I'M SURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THE IN AN INTERNATIONAL
CANNABIS FARMERS ASSOCIATION.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THIS IS A MINOR CHANGE -- BUT IN
REALITY IS A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
TO THE SMALL PRODUCERS
ESPECIALLY COTTAGE PRODUCERS
SPECIAL IN THE NORTH COAST -- SO
THAT THEIR LICENSES ARE
CONSISTENT WITH OTHERS WHICH
WILL ULTIMATELY.
AND HOPEFULLY A REDUCE THE COST
OF THESE LICENSES -- WHEN
THEY'RE? TO BE DISTINGUISHED BY.
SQUARE FEET INSTEAD OF NUMBER OF
PLANTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS BY
MEMBERS.
CNN DO I HAVE A MOTION ON THE
BILL.
DEMOLITION ON THE BILL THE
SECRETARY IS GLOBAL.
AB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS SOME RE REFER TO
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
SENATORS GALGIANI HI JOHNNY I
WILL.
WELL I HAVE A ZERO ZERO I VALLEY
GLAZER [inaudible]
TRANSLATIONS.
BUT WE WILL HOLD THE WILL BE SO
MUCH THANK YOU
.
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK AT THIS TIME AND WE
WILL RESUME IN FIVE MINUTES
OKAY AT THIS POINT WE ARE
RETURNING TO AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE AND I'LL ASK THE
SECRETARY TO LIFT THE CALL ON
THE BILLS THAT.
A SONG CALLED.
WE HAVE.
TWO ONE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AB FOR FIFTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ARAMBULA THE VOTE IS.
THREE ZERO WILL SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK ALLEN YES.
OKAY ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATORS THAT VALLEY.
KELLY I GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE.
OKAY THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
AND NOW WILL MOVE TO A BEFORE
FIFTY BIAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA.
A BEFORE FIFTIES THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS DALLY.
KELLY I GLAZER GLAZER I AM BILLS
OUT AND FINALLY AB EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
THE VOTERS.
THREE TO ZERO AB EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT TO MOTIONS DO PATTERSON
REFERRED TO BUSINESS PROFESSIONS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SENATOR
STALLEY [inaudible]
SENATOR GLAZERS.
GLAZER I AM BILLS ALSO OUT
WE
HAVE ONE ITEM REMAINING AB TEN
EIGHTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER QUE HAN.
AND THAT BILL WILL BE HELD FOR
NOW IN THE SENATE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE SO THAT INCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS OF THE DAY.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US